hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play y night
okay you guys talk to me like I was a
two-year-old and I appreciate that cuz
that's how you get the message to me and
here we go it's 1:35 to 64 1 3 5 2 6 4
Rumble oh hello oh hey I know
ah ha female Winkie oh yeah how we go
see the females yeah okay that was
really creepy I'm sorry for that
oh that's not it okay must be the one
downstairs then I get the volume a bit
it's a bit too quiet okay I'm thinking I
must be getting close
up but what good hello receptive visit
me any more days all right here will you
leave me alone hanging huh what will you
were punting me no baby nah I'm here
aren't I Oh
mmm sorry lady least a cheese alright so
the female wing is it down here is it
down yonder away
the music has started again uh unlocked
I'm coming for you it was burning
everything was burning everyone was
screaming pleading for help I could
nearly see them like embodying screams
okay it was hot
oh hi hi hey hey buddy okay you're gone
now okay that's good that's nice I like
that yeah you do
hello baby I'm here I'm here for you
hello grace uh grace grace could you not
be in the creepy-ass hospital
oh oh I cannot move anymore
I'm I I've lost control of the game this
is where it sucks out my soul and I get
replaced by an evil demon okay there
about lots of things David you promised
to come and visit me you promised to
protect me but know things will always
be as you like okay I'm sorry
did you know David why I didn't kill you
while I was hunting others because
mother grace wouldn't let me know she is
gone thanks to Sophia huh what
ah-hah hello forget I'm not gonna forget
forget you man geez
other grace so I'm guessing that's why
grace was in here in the first place
because she had split personality one
murdering one not oh this is familiar I
said the game began hello hello lights
shifting I can't move my mouth so I
can't look around and I guys say I have
a great appreciation for how much custom
stuff they did in this game I always
captured abducted knocked out restrained
it was an ordinary rainy gloomy day that
I came to visit grace she was afraid of
thunders I remember I remember when we
first met it was raining ok so yeah I
really do appreciate all the custom
stuff that goes into games like this
just people who you know don't expect to
ever be paid and do all this amazing
work whoa well if this is kind of
familiar because this is kind of the
atmosphere that has been you know
blipping into the mind every once in a
while throughout the game
yeah they trying to run here those
chains not be in my way haha oh it's way
do I go
oh um chains barring my okay oh shut up
it's really unnerving can you stop with
the music
cuz I'm blimey uh-huh
what is that I see something shiny I see
a shiny ah what was that
Oh race night
haha we're going on I can't get over
there Oh music shut up geez oli crap but
little by little a little a little a
little ooh oh my
ha ha
perfectly normal I'm totally perfectly
normal being in the same ventilation
shaft from hell
what's uh what needs to be done is not
put her in a jail oh okay we'll solve
nothing
what she needs is treatment right yeah
Patrick Patrick paws keys right I think
I've already proven broken Minds can be
he uh-huh right yeah maybe Grayson
Sophia are the same purple oh that would
be the final twist cuz there's already
been a couple twists but that would be
the final twist Oh eyeballs in the wall
all these years David all these years
and you can tell me about your parents
and you can call yourself a husband I
never said I was good one
eyeballs in the wall would make a great
death metal band name don't you agree
eyeballs in the wall oh yeah so [ __ ]
metal man okay
[Music]
huh grace what wait who's wait what wait
who's grace I thought you were grace oh
you're the other grace what's with the
babies this biz this baby Sophia I I
have no idea what's going on I have no
more guesses I'm utterly confused so
everybody I can't wait wait what
happened oh hello
is everyone confused good yeah my mind
is thoroughly unraveling thank you very
much I will not go into the abyss
kiss my abyss huh okay I want to do this
huh oh oh I get to toss to see where the
path is oh hello or not
herp there we go aha so if I hit the
paths okay I need to get some of these
over there hello hands lots of bricks
I'm thankful for that herp derp lease is
not a stacking puzzle era knows how much
I love those and this is really creative
use I never would have guessed thought
to use this come on Hector
da da da ha ha jump shot not right
through though okay so if I just up her
up yeah let's see ha
BAM [ __ ] ow I'm hot ah dammit missed ha
ha ha god I miss a gun and I have a lot
of bricks but it's hard to get him over
there gah
come on stay on the platform darn I
gotta go George why time ha oh don't
paint a my my balls oh come on I thought
it was there damn it ok mmm oh there's
got take for a bar where that where the
bloody hell is it well the bleedin
bloody hell is it where is it
I'm trying I'm trying folks I can't
carry more than one at a time I just got
it
oh come on I can get I can get them over
there can i I can I I set a couple on
there about four I just really angle it
damn it damn it stay on the platform
jeez there we go ah Birds nutters ok
they really angle it uh-uh
oh god oh god
Oh Delgado
haha okay give me while I do this real
quickly like oh okay did I get enough
over there gotten a few up okay so if I
have this here
the only other logical place where it
could be that I can jump from this over
to the right there we go there we go
makin bacon up god damn still that's a
really long frickin way
copy right here-ish bah up what of it
what ah baloney this baloney is baloney
this is baloney malarkey
really nice idea but a little too big
Lana what that I did I what I what huh
ah come on
okay it's got to be far off to the left
then there we go jeez okay all right all
right all right go back another brick
maybe there's one way to like it I could
carry one brick I just use it as a
testing thing real short tosses where it
would logically be Oh God now what oh oh
okay then
alright maybe I don't even need a brick
if that's all that happens I'll carry
this brick but I won't be happy about it
do you remember when we first met sure
don't oh wait you don't need to remember
David because I will put those memories
as I like okay wait are you Sophia where
are you are you see are you Sophia are
you grace why are those three so orderly
like right there ah okay all right huh
nope try over here
ha failure she's like this is just a
pain in the ass this is a pain in the
ass what this is not all ideas are great
let me just say that I mean you can get
creative but I mean come on now where
the hell is it where the bloody balls is
it where the oh you got to be kidding me
ah where the bleedin balls is it if not
there it's not there it's not there it's
not there where the hell is it well
where whoa what the [ __ ] huh well how
about what the [ __ ] what in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I want to finish this where the
[ __ ] is it okay
I've tried here here here here in here
ah ah okay this is just ridiculous okay
now that you got to be kidding me
you just you can't be serious right you
cannot be serious
let's kill this this can't be serious
what - what the Frick up [ __ ] ah ha what
the balls you uh I don't I don't even I
don't even know how to deal with you
this is oh god this is annoying this is
annoying at first I was like what a
creative use of the mechanics of the
game and then I was like holy balls this
is really really really really really
really really annoying oh my oh my just
oh oh my I mean if this was maybe a few
platforms and if you know the bricks
were readily available along the entire
route yeah I could I could totally
understand tolerating this okay jumped
in front of me haha but this this CAW
Gor blimey governor Gor blimey I'm
probably you probably don't see because
I bet I bet I'm willing to bet that I
cut stuff out of this if you're seeing
this now so you probably didn't see all
of it all of the hell that I have
wrought huh
great go again can we do this again
because I love jumping through this over
and over and over in a series of hellish
trial and error there nothing nothing
says good game mechanics like dumb
lock okay seriously I like I let off
watch not ours I like I like a lot of
the things in this custom story but some
of them I just hate with up pure white
burning passion like this this is just
one of those things that I do not like
is it over here
yes it is what do you know can I go
through it again and again and again and
again and again
with a one brick at a time dragging it
longer and farther each time each time I
drag it farther and farther way maybe
the hands are a clue maybe the hands are
clue cuz it kinda no no maybe they're
not a clue there we go
oh I got a double I got a double whammy
and now guess what I get to jump again
yay with efj reward comes an equally
severe punishment of having to run back
and forth and back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth
huzzah it's great I love it I love it so
much
so much in fact that I'm just oh God
haha I'm gonna run out of bricks
you know just cuz apparently I'm too
stupid for this puzzle i'ma run out of
bricks god I love holding on his shift
button and jamming my spacebar
I couldn't imagine anything being more
fun I couldn't possibly think of one
itty-bitty little thing that could be
more fun than what I'm doing right now
yay Oh didn't quite make it though no
I'm one shy it's even not delightful I
get to do it all over again and possibly
one more time cuz if I get this wrong
then maybe you know maybe maybe did
maybe I'll be able to get it but
probably not this I mean oh no no
yeah I get to do it again ah and
possibly one more time maybe two if I'm
lucky maybe yay is the best thing ever
I can't imagine anything more you know
atmosphere breaking breaking up the
rhythm of what could have been a really
nice playthrough there we go
God dang gosh dang Oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you so hard
I will oh god I hate you oh god don't
don't do that again I oh god I hate that
Holly
balls I hated that oh I can't believe
how much anger I am holding inside me
right now the rage the intense rage
right now forget David
ah but you should be thankful I made you
remember again
ah I always make you remember again no
matter how deep you bury me no matter
how deep you bury me speak more
monotonous lee dick I have so much
burning rage inside my heart so much
diabolical insane rage do you know why
Sophia cause of victory is why tonight I
don't know because she likes scrub so
much hmm especially when they are white
did you know the one she was now is was
Patrick I thought you were talking about
the show Scrubs
the night before your last visit she
organized all the patients here and took
over the hospital when her doctor ethnic
now belongs to Sophia mm-hmm okay and
now I go fast now I go fast
I don't mind storytelling set-pieces at
all don't mind it at all but seriously
come on
burning white-hot rage hello lightbulb
I haven't even put a single light bulb
in anything I have not I have not I
wouldn't even be that scared if
something popped up right now I would
not be because I'm just so angry at that
part I'm so angry at what that was at
the decision how how do you get such a
great game where I just compliment you
on all being great set pieces that you
have made oh look it's a fire water
monster in that lovely that's the only
incredible set pieces that you have made
yay Oh Holly balls Oh get out of here
not not not not not even gonna worry
about you
weird fire water monsters whatever you
are don't even know don't even care yeah
don't care at this point I don't care
okay I was so happy before I was I was I
was so happy so happy before and now
it's all crushed taken away from me
like a shadow in the night charge our
drunk
[Music]
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
what's going on does that do I can't
move it again no confirming so no
nothing
oh you know what you know I probably I'm
probably for all the time that I cut out
in that last part I'm probably good now
so I'm gonna whoa no hang on let me let
me look at this okay hi Sophia Tommy I
taught her how to use nice huh okay yeah
well um I'm beginning to think that
you're both the same person which is
really really quite disturbing
hello string what oh hi
[Music]
okay why are these balls of morphine how
do I get out of this place
oh you I use that chair okay here we go
and I got the string which probably
means that I can get that key out of
there get that key out of there yeah I
probably just gonna finish this all in
one I don't care how much is left I'm
just gonna finish it hurt dirt without a
hook hook what do I need it I combo does
not work oh I know I get a hook maybe
back with the water monsters um back
like before wait what's down here hey
what's in here hi hook uh hollow needle
her ker trunk yeah hook who picked up a
hawk yeah like a mouse God the best look
at me go I'm the best sir was down there
come ere you tell me are you almost dry
oh yeah I'm gonna strangle you okay hurt
ah got it
nailed it now what do I do with this
what what what do I do with this
illumination ah the key back over here
then the door the Lord
beginning okay what you got for me baby
what you got come on Sofia my love or
grace my love I'm not sure which one's
my love run David oh okay Wow
oh god it's the fire monsters again God
here
oh yeah Geyer what did what hey what
what God come on follow that there we go
Oh Oh balls old balls old balls balls
balls oh all things that happened all
the past that I forgot I was forced to
forget and wanted to forget why did I
listen to her why did I listen to her
and run okay grace listen where where am
I oh good yeah mm-hmm I feel pretty good
see you next week okay all right thanks
baby you're the best
wait where'd you go all right whatever
whatevs I feel so relaxed don't tell me
that was like all one big dream sequence
gave me while I will go through your
desk mr. Pitts lady I'm gonna laugh if
that was all just one you don't have to
carry your parents memory on your
shoulder anymore because it might not
let you forget
that was creepy what was that all about
I have a bad feeling about this I have a
very bad feeling I've got I get scuff
heel something about will the way she
said that it was quite chilling what
where am I
what is this whatever going on should
probably use the elevator instead okay
whatever you say boss you too man
quickly quickly aha
what what what is going on I'm utterly
confused like I have been for most of
this game I am utterly confused okay
those are the stairs not taking those oh
look at all these Oh what it gave me
while I go through everybody's mail oh
god they know I have to go through all
these oh god no oh come on oh don't make
alright fine I'm gonna break my break my
habit any second here I know one of
these probably has some crucial
information Oh God
but just stop stop stop Oh gasp stop
okay stop I stopped my son I stopped oh
what the
well this is weird I don't think this is
an outside this is rather strange na
yeah na ha
what was that why is this one blinking
what's on this seat did I need ah now
that David's trauma is gone we can begin
our experiments next step what ah
what I know they're tossing me around so
much I'm utterly confused who be steppin
who dost ya David maybe I don't know Oh
No and there you have it that's the doc
BAM yeah I don't even I was so utterly
confused and angry and scared the whole
time I don't even know what to think of
that I mean it was oh don't get me wrong
there was a lot of very creative stuff
out there but I can't say that it was
like great because it kept going back
and forth so much it was so confusing
the storyline was so broken that nobody
could possibly make any sense of it I
don't even think there could be sense
out of that it was going back and forth
with grace so much
the characters were indistinguishable
from each other in the voice egg but
other than that other than my criticisms
it still was exceptionally creative and
that's a good thing
it's good thing to have creative stuff
and there were some very good scares in
that although she doesn't love me
anymore my ex-girlfriend oh well that's
that's sad that's sad for giving you
sexy voice for David
sei-chan why yeah I mean I don't want to
criticize people too much for making
really really creative games I just
can't say that it was the best amnesia
custom story that I've ever played which
is fine I mean that's perfectly fine
doll are gonna be I'm gonna be perfect
perfect things and a lot of work went
into this one so I appreciate all the
team members I'll see all these people
that had a hand in making this game and
obviously me I'm just a youtuber I've
with an opinion probably not a right
opinion anyway it's just my opinion
don't let it like anybody else is just
what I think my criticisms are my own
I've never made a game in my life so
take it for what it is
so thank you all is that the end you're
gonna be eyes they're gonna be something
at the end of the credits because there
might be you know enjoy notice the
symbolism I didn't notice some symbolism
but hear your comments freezer
David Sawyer's ended see you in another
story what did David do wrong other than
visit his wife in the in the mental
institution I don't think David did
anything wrong I think he was like I
think it was like exposed to the
memories that were part of Greece and I
don't know I don't think David actually
did anything so I guess that's it ok so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh [ __ ] oh hey Z look at me go
[Music]